c'est un débat complexe qui se déroulent
encore derrière cette porte comment
comptabiliser et donc rémunérer les
dépassements d'horaires des facteurs
d'après l'inspection du travail qui a
contrôlé le 30 mars 2010 la plateforme
de préparation et de distribution du
courrier de besançon les dépassements
d'horaires ils sont massifs
ce jour là deux tiers des agents
relevant du droit privé déclarent
dépasser occasionnellement ou
systématiquement les horaires fixés par
l'employeur certains jusqu'à une heure
et demie de plus chaque jour
l'administration formule alors dans son
rapport l'accusation de travail
dissimulé selon le syndicat sud ptt qui
s'est constituée partie civile dans ce
dossier
les facteurs qui refusent ces heures
supplémentaires non rémunérées sont même
parfois sanctionnée par leur direction
ya pas de doute y à la poste pour
prendre en compte les dépassements
horaires il ya pas d'enregistrement du
temps de travail
et si on a déjà eu le cas c'est pour ça
que nous on est là on a attaqué la poste
par rapport à ça
si les collègues en fait à un moment
donné refusé de faire la charge dans le
temps imparti aimé y avait des sanctions
ou à chaque fois le redis il ya des
insuffisances professionnelles ce qui
est faux je veux dire il ya un outil à
la poste qui calcule la charge est
détournée qu'un ordinateur qui pas du
tout sera ultra irréel et jure c'est un
vrai problème quand on perd de l'emploi
chaque fois tous les deux ans bah oui on
y arrive plus quoi on n'y arrive plus et
les personnes sont obligées à près de
dépasser ou prendre plus tôt et donc
travaillons à dire gratuitement et non
pas les horaires payer de son côté la
poste représenté ici par un avocat
parisien réfute toutes les accusations
dont elle fait l'objet
la société refuse pourtant de mettre en
place une pointeuse qui permettrait de
mesurer réellement le temps de travail
de chaque salarié
la défense assure par ailleurs que le
respect des horaires collectifs doivent
se mesurer sur un cycle de huit à douze
semaines fragilisant ainsi le contrôle
ponctuel de l'inspection du travail
cette inspection du travail qui depuis a
dénoncé des pratiques similaires de
travail dissimulé sur le secteur de
pontarlier et cette fois sur une durée
plus longue
six mois une inspection qui avait été
déclenché suite au suicide d'un postier